ryan brian got all that extra room over
there i like room to
open my legs that's what time it is yeah
right it's good
i'm doing yeah i'm trying to touch my
thighs man you know we got big thoughts
oh yeah he's got any big thighs yeah you
can't just be rolling over now chappelle
did 315
for we were going for four but i was
going before budget
is that right yeah i'm not mad at that
and you don't you've never really lifted
no just girls he's been lifting with us
now yeah but now but like yeah
for months how much stronger have you
gotten in the process oh
two when i went first when i first
was like make a wish the first day of
that not true yeah i get on the bench
little buddy
yeah i couldn't do it he was like
shaking it's funny man
i was doing 3 15. yeah i couldn't even
[ __ ] uh
what was it what did i you had me try
225 yeah
yeah yeah we tried 225 and i couldn't
even
try it another time let's try another
time
this is all we do is lift these heavy
things like oh man
you get you sent me he just could say
ugh
i hate being so strong with the
deadlifts 475
five times i showed it to i like to show
it to people who are into weightlifting
and they all get real quiet wait when
you just get quiet they go
you just do straight up cardio right no
here's the thing chappelle i'm glad you
asked
um i i play tennis and i lift weights
thank you though
and um he's looking exactly the same i
don't
know
held on his body has never changed
because he's a thing he's thinking
his face gets wrinklier his body stays
this way that's what you do brian
you'll tell the lie to me you think he
will say it's not that
i i i it's like when i was brandon one
time we were whole foods and i go um
should i get the whey protein or the
animal doesn't matter though does it
doesn't matter
because it doesn't matter because just
protein it's now your body's not gonna
you're gonna do weight isolating you're
gonna blow up it's not gonna happen so
we're outside you're ready for a
marathon it gets me mad when you talk
somewhere he has no respect here's the
thing about being older now here's the
thing
i decided to play tag my kids were
locking themselves in
the truck my my access truck and then
what i would do is they'd open the door
and then i'd try to open the door
and then they would lock it the thing is
i was doing that on a pla on a
parking lot okay and i kept running
around the car
you understand that he's sweating well
now daddy's not just sweating because
then they would make a bold forward to
the woods and i would
i'm in shape bro i would just sprint
after thing yeah
see i i've got some i'm i got shows
this weekend in tampa friday saturday i
got until friday i got
till friday come on to be able to move
actually move my legs
out oh my god i
i pulled weird muscles i pulled a weird
muscle where my ass you know where my
ass connects and my
yeah the the muscle the tendon at it
connects to my ass
and my lower knee that's a problem yep
and then i got this
thin band of fire in my lower back i
[ __ ] myself
up yeah yeah don't sprint
well speaking of older dudes do you know
who i ran into this morning
uh blue jam michael j white
oh dude spawn dude
that's a big man insane i don't know how
old he is
but he's moving he's closing out my age
is he yeah for sure
and he's he's a he's a the stuntman
really nice guy yeah and an app super
super really nice
you tell them what's up yeah i did i
said because i i geek out over that dude
i love you or what oh yes
oh [ __ ] yeah he's dude he is but you
geek
out over uh just real quick over spawn
or
what like why why would you geek out
over him all those strongest martial art
films he's done yep
take that down no no no no no hey like
where did you say which one
uh blood and bone bone or bone and blood
here's the thing about me i geek out
over martial martial art films it
doesn't matter
like if they're like low budget good i
don't like that i'm stopping
with his work that's all i know spahn
he's worked with kimbo michael j white
is the real [ __ ] deal real deal and
i'm saying this as well and i don't give
a [ __ ] what anybody says
you put that guy in the cage now right
[ __ ] now does he beat herschel walker
no no no i'm not giving it down wait you
don't think he'll be herself
hersh walker trains first of all let me
excuse me excuse me
i know you've seen never back down or
whatever but um
walker fought and strike for it's a real
competition mike
michael jack but you don't think michael
j white can do that he's a big
athletic strong guy who studies martial
arts
he does he'll teach you how to jab he
would show these guys where they pull
back he's like just go straight
that's all good all good the problem is
he's never actually i don't believe and
you might be wrong i might be wrong
please correct me
he's never actually gotten into a cage
or a ring and actually fought
that is significant it's like when you
say those dudes are false advertisement
i'm saying there's a big difference
between people that make the walk get in
a ring in a cage
train for that specifically and fight in
an mma bout like hershel walker
who's also a who's elsewhere he also
trained he also trained at aka
yeah with some samples but he probably
fought in competitions i don't think
michael j
white i might be wrong maybe maybe
karate or taekwondo
taekwondo competitions and now you're
ready this might hurt your feelings
those don't count
they don't count this now this might
hurt daddy those don't count that
doesn't hurt my feelings
okay i'm very aware of that because the
way you're aware of it now if i i'll
kill you with my feet if i have to
okay wait what does this say he's
competed in a he's competing he's never
has
but doesn't mean he doesn't know like
some fundamentals or like you know he's
been a martial artist which is cool
it also doesn't mean that he's not a
very physically
specialist have you ever seen
jean-claude van damme when he saw the
diaz brothers outside gold's gym and
then was
teach him a technique to do inside the
octagon no that hurts my feelings
i saw that too why why well explain
that's no different than vin diesel
coming up to [ __ ] france and ghana be
like
you know and they do it
they grew up they were grew but shut the
[ __ ] up and they do it all the time it
happens
do they really they do it all the time
where the diaz brothers listening
yeah they were cool because they're nice
guys and it's also jean-claude van damme
so you can entertain it then when they
get on their car they're like what the
[ __ ] man
really they're not gonna use it so okay
so a lot of the dudes that do the acting
uh in the martial art films you're just
saying they're not legit fighters
no what about bruce lee and jet lake no
the answer is absolutely not i thought
bruce lee
he's he'd never flat he was a an
acrobatic
actor he's never fought was a he's a
businessman and
carried the torch from martial arts and
did wonderful things but as far as
like actual fighting he did do he did do
an arm bar
and a legit arm bart and enter the
dragon
it's pretty cool that was a japanese jiu
jitsu arm bar this is he
did you see once the time in uh um
in hollywood there well there's that
movie but did you you know uh when brad
pitt
froze them you know uh jean labelle
really did that to bruce lee
that's where that story comes from
that's not a fake story i did remember
jean labelle
actually hemmed up bruce lee and beat
the [ __ ] out of him i do
that's the room bruce lee was five seven
one twenty he's a pioneer though
nicely he's tiny he was tiny jean la
belle's a gorilla
gina bell is a guerrilla and was a
judoka guy and a wrestler and a
hardcore joke yeah and and i have you
know
and so unless so you're saying basically
you're saying unless you've like
competed
in that world you don't it's not that
michael jai white isn't a real athlete
probably and has in very strong and very
you know physically you look at him and
he's big and
posing i'd rather see rogan versus him
in a fight
something like that something like that
makes more sense really but i mean when
you say michael j
white if you're if you compare them to
professionals
professionals who do it for a living
it's just a different thing
it's like you taking tips when you do
sets for me in houston
from your funny uncle at the barbecue
you're like have you ever done stanley
nah yeah but he's hilarious though dude
he's been funny forever
like uh okay i guess i'll listen to him
it's it's like when you
so so when you're strong physically big
guy but you
when you first tried the bench i mean
it's a bad example but
another good example is this like you
see guys you guys see
but it is but it is similar though if
you guys if you watch guys hit mitts you
can get really good at hitting knits
like really good you can look awesome
yeah i mean you can pop pop up and look
amazing and move around and stuff like
that
the difference between that and getting
in a ring with a guy who's hitting you
and learning distance and patterns it's
not even
in the same conversation but i was
watching this video of him explaining
things to kimbo slice
no well kim must but you gotta watch
i mean if you watch the video would it's
not that he wouldn't but wait wait it's
not
it's not don't hate him because i don't
it's not that michael jai white can't go
can't go you know because he saw
maybe he took a boxing but he
understands boxing that you know he says
it with your boxing go straight from
here as opposed to here
okay watch how quick he was that's
that's that's that's what you just
pulled up
you saw that video before that's a box
oh it's not that he can't give advice in
that sense like in a vacuum
but but i'll well but he shouldn't and i
love mikey
what he shouldn't he should have kids
it's no different than somebody never
doing stand-up
going after you giving you a tag for
your closing joke
you'd be like that's interesting that he
has the
all right it's just yeah it's just you
know you're just not in that
pool it's crazy i i i didn't know okay
especially
but if you're saying that to a guy who
does it for a living
the assumption is that they don't know
that that they haven't trained in that
right yeah so so we were doing fighting
we were doing fire and kids 3d uh-huh
and brandon and i were doing sprints
watch out cookies
just move it out the way all right so
now notice the speed of the first
two right ready yeah
that's one two okay now here's the third
one
don't let me hit it ready
i think he was only trying to help kimbo
they're like legit being like dude maybe
try this out yeah oh maybe just for the
movie
i don't know it's more i don't know i
don't know what the context well that
was the uh but i know michael j white
and i know he's a really good person it
was a fight scene
uh they had in that movie in kimbo like
they were playing like uh
guys in prison and you know michael jai
white fought like seven dudes pretty
much and
kicked their ass so when you do when you
do something i know about is
combat on film the one thing you never
want to do
on film doing comment is actually do
real fighting yeah you want to
exaggerate your punches
you want the martial arts stuff so guys
who really fight would look terrible on
film because it's two
my friend wes chatham was doing a movie
with uh sylvester stallone
okay i forget which movie and wes trains
boxing like is that wild card all the
time
so he was like oh i know boxing is
perfect for me so they're in a fight
scene with sylvester and his hands are
up he's got this
inspector goes cut he goes dude what are
you doing
he's like what like i train boxing he's
like this isn't
real fighting yeah he's like i want you
to throw he's like go against all your
instincts i want you to throw from
the ground and make it real dramatic and
loose
he's like so those straight punches like
that technique this isn't the space and
you know when you when you translate so
what we we did firing kids
were sprinting and i i studied when high
school
i was on track because i threw the
javelin and i and i i did
i and i high school and i did uh i did
and i did
uh polvo because nobody else would right
yeah i pulled like seven feet
i don't want to talk about that but i
learned a little bit about
sprinting right so from high school so
wait so he's
he's i notice he's sprinting and he's
running like this
and i go i go hey hey you know i don't
know if you know this but when you
sprint
you want to run and he goes and he goes
he goes
wait hold on hold on
i was running the way apollo creed ran
in the movie but did you want to teach
me how to sprint because i only
i only tried my hardest with the best
coaches in the world six years
and because i wanted to be in the
combine so everything was about
sprinting that's all i did
yeah and i worked with the best guys
like where you get three points
about how you explode yeah how low you
stay where and and i i
that was the only time i've ever been a
little bit embarrassed
because i went oh no that's all he did
that happens all the time
yeah that was his job right so if you
teach like i've i've
made the mistake of teaching you'll love
this i taught nate marquart
and and even sugar shawn like i didn't
tease him but i said um do you guys ever
i i don't know why you guys don't use
back kick if you just turn your
shoulders because actually it
i've used that a lot in real tournaments
it actually works it hurts my feelings
and so so nate just nate who's so nice
nate was this reason it was like a long
time ago
and it goes um i i don't really like to
turn my back on somebody in a fight and
i was like
and yeah because well maybe you just
don't know what to offer like
i knew but i was just like i'd rather
you offer me your ass no
this all does make sense because it it
makes me think about that time when
i was die hard on the fact that i ran a
four 340.
and yeah show me actually you were like
you're like you didn't run a four three
four no no you did not run a fourth
through forty i was like
that's what i was like you know how fast
you know how many people do that i
didn't know that
until they until he showed me he this
year at the metcalf i think not this
year but that kept
running four three three which is
unheard of yeah that's why
he and one other dude i think like two
people a a year
hit like two four three one percent nfl
i'm like yeah i ran four three four in
high school
i know and then then he showed me a
video of someone running before three
but but then i told you i said i i cause
you're such a good person i believe you
think that
yes but i know your coach holding the
thing was full of [ __ ] i know and i'm
sitting here i'm like
i lied to you why would i lie to you
because yeah that point
but then then he showed me someone
running for it i was like oh i didn't do
that yeah
people are like there's no way of hell
it's like insane it's randy moss
dion jordan shouldn't anyone get like
four two i mean there's a guy who ran
like a four two eight i think chris
johnson ran the fastest dion sanders in
a fast one too
but it's like i mean i mean what does
that even look like
it's just it's a blur they're so fast
guys who are
in the combine you said they do like
it's electrical
why procedures wide receivers that are
like are really amazing
they run a 4-5 you see that regularly
four five four five is like the average
that that's fast four or five is fast
look at that
chris johnson was such a beast oh my god
4-2 damn champ bailey 4-2
wow that's so fast man
quick break yep this episode is brought
to you by unleashed with dingo and danny
a new podcast fueled by monster energy
unleash gets up close and personal with
the best alternative
action in motorsports so get ready for
great stories inside secrets
from the world's best athletes and
trailblazers don't miss out on all the
action
new episodes drop every two weeks on
mondays listen wherever you get your
podcast or watch on monster energy's
youtube
unleashed with danny and the dingo
fueled by monster energy
10 000 that's right 10 000 makes the
highest quality best fitting most
comfortable training shorts
you can get all right 10 000 they have
three core training shorts built for all
the ways you train
the interval short versatile great for
hit training spin classes
short runs anything you think of the
foundation short built for durability
tough gym days outdoor hiking whatever
you want to do outdoors these
then the sessions short super
lightweight perfect for running yoga
hanging out watching tv 10 000 is direct
to consumer company no middleman so you
get the best shorts at the best
prices right and they linked up with
over 200 athletes that test their gear
to ensure the perfect design
fabric trims all right dominic cruz got
in the action he's helping design these
shorts
pick the short that is best for your
training and then personalize it with
custom liner inseam options
they have over 9 500 5 star reviews
say what these are some of the best
shorts around kids
they sent me a pair i love them 10 000
is offering
you guys 15 off your purchase go to 10
000 dot cc enter the code fighter to
receive 50 off your purchase that's 10
000
spelled out t-e-n-t-h-o-u-s-a-n-d
dot c-c enter the code fighter for
15 off welcome man thank you for having
me
yeah i have you man good seeing you
james you're just talking about 40 yard
dashes so you
came just in time and i know you i want
to talk to you about like a five seconds
you look like a sprinter you know
me i'm a big-time big-time sprinter
i run the 40 and 8.
you tell us when you're racing we're
good we're good i got to see this floor
too well jamie jamie kennedy is going to
get out there and run for us
yeah did you ever run a 40 in high
school or anything dude did you learn
sports uh basketball golf
actually bowling believe it or not my
family was a big bowler you're just
letting you're letting your beard do
whatever it was
it's a protest is it a pandemic this is
what happens when you stay in your house
for a year and you start questioning
things you have you know what you have
i'm gonna say it you have a castaway
beard
you have a castaway beer dude i love it
i put stuff in it to make it look a
little bit more presentable beard butter
yeah and it doesn't look like it did it
dude your hair looks like you're waiting
to take flight i like
i'm just no i was just performing in a
bush last night
we performed at a a hostel a hospital
they said oh it's going to be a great
gift yeah they're like
it's an artist it's an artist community
and then i see like one sweet smoking a
joint another sweet taking an edible and
i'm like i was like why is there bits
i'm like this is just a hostel
was like yeah and i'm like this is
ground zero like
they had a green room for us was this in
the pandemic yeah yes
i don't know it's a hot gig
it actually was fun but at the same time
yeah the green room was pretty funny we
had they had starbursts for us and stuff
just starbursts
but you know they're really splurging
who does that buy some eggs
and they open them up you always open
them up yeah they're always unwrapped
open them and put them in a bowl
just yellows and oranges do you get the
starburst
in the bowl jamie have you been uh
touring it all during the pandemic could
you shut it down and just go with
unobama
i you know what i drive so but not
regular places yet i do i did phoenix
okay um i did like a big show within a
park
i did i did a lot of diego like i did
diego last night
like four times or not well acc has
opened grand comedy is open yeah
so i've been doing like the shows with
like young entrepreneurs
and like who are doing stuff but the
clubs i'm now just starting i believe
i'm gonna make my way to austin
yep and i believe and i'm i'm gonna go
to side splitters it's a place i always
play every
year where is that tampon that's right
and philly probably play the punch line
yep but i haven't really i just started
performing inside like two weeks ago
you don't you don't do the tampam pro i
used to
i just was but i got a deal like with
side splitters it was like a young
kid who took over the club and he pretty
much gives me brian thompson yeah
yeah he's the man and i'd rather just go
in and not take any money up front and
see what i sell yeah
so i like that i like that guy yeah has
the
the whole covert thing been tough for
you just been what have you been doing
dude
i i've been i've actually been pretty i
mean i don't know
it sounds weird i've been pretty
productive like i've been doing a lot of
stuff that i normally wouldn't do you
know
like i'm fixing up my place and getting
all my online stuff taking old clips and
putting all the you know words and
captions and i've been
i've been like getting my house in order
and like paying back taxes
like stuff that we never do because
we're always on a plane yeah force you
to shut down and like do stuff
especially people online
if you don't have like a lot of people
like especially comics struck up a
podcast or the pandemic yeah
or they're like thinking about their
social media now
yeah you you uh we performed at uh
uh where was that where the airplanes
were with some private plane hangar
yeah yeah no it wasn't in santa monica
was that kind of remember yeah we
performed there i performed a few shows
with you
oh yeah we did a zoom we did a zoom i've
been like
i don't know i guess i started
performing maybe october yeah
and i just it's been so
now the last month it's been pretty busy
i know you guys seem like you can't
kind of kept going yeah never stop but
yeah
you know but won't stop can't stop i
mean
you know this is what it is
beast mode
better at relaxing or not doing anything
and that it's more neurotic i think
yeah it's like yeah yeah people can just
sit like i know people are just like
doing nothing just been hanging out
it just might be wow man that's
impressive yeah that's not i do like
like the pandemic fortunate to shut down
like oh i work way too much like when
you yeah
when you have to chill out i'm like yeah
i'm doing too much man no i
it gave me perspective like i didn't
mind chilling out
you know i've been fortunate enough to
do this for like 25 years we're on the
road
that's what we're talking about you been
to us for a hot second dude i was
watching
randomly they told me you're coming on
and then i think on friday or
saturday i was at home with the kids and
scream was on
oh and i was like holy [ __ ] dude just
doing a long back back wow yeah that was
back in the day yeah it's almost 25
years
yeah yeah it's uh it was it was a good
one you know it was one of those you've
been entertainment forever dude
probably 1990
91 it's kind of when i started making
money you think you'll always do it
do you have a fantasy of doing anything
else you know it's so funny bro because
it's interesting because someone who has
been doing it i think you've probably
been doing it almost as long as me
30 years you tell me i
feel that it's changed so much but maybe
i'm in denial
maybe i don't want to be old man it
yells a cloud but i do
feel it's just so different now and it's
great but it's also different like
am i crazy to say it's lost certain
luster well i don't know i think for me
i feel like as an
older dude now and i'm as long as i'm
so during covet i wrote a whole sort of
hour and i kind of threw it away
mm-hmm i've never done this before but i
went um not i'm just gonna throw it away
yeah because i wasn't i was like i'm
getting to a point now where i have
where my observations can be original
like i i'm going to think about
how i feel about something as opposed to
getting my opinion from a book or from
someone else
good and that challenge has been
interesting because
what i find is people actually want to
hear from the old guy
and so in that sense it's been a really
interesting
kind of transformation i've kind of been
like well why why can't i come up with
the ideas that people are talking about
as opposed to
regurgitating them from somewhere else
and that's that's just a new thing for
me so maybe in that sense it's a shot in
the arm so i do think in that sense as
long as you're challenging yourself with
some new thing
the response has been really good but
before that
i was like you guys have 60 years of
entertainment i know
you know what you guys look
no but it's like we would have to go
like this
like please please please and now like
this is an example you can start your
own thing
create your own audience do your own
lane
but i think the mystery of hollywood
like is so
different now like does there's people
in idaho they're like oh i know that
[ __ ] because i saw behind the scenes
and the tick tock it's like there's no
mystery anymore yeah the fourth wall
yeah
and it's different and there's also like
there's no like there's no like
major celebrities anymore like everyone
has their niche like
you're never going to get another like
leonardo dicaprio or you know it's just
it's just different like everyone has
their lane and then it's like
building out of that lane david blaine
was telling me that
he but back in the day he would do a
special
and it would trend for two years like so
he'd do nuts
well he'd do he'd do a special and
literally it'd be an abc thing if you
rate it really high yeah
did you see him levitate yeah now what
did he do he had those balloons
and they took him off into the air like
he held on the balloons
well he was talking to a youtuber and
the youtuber goes
man if you do that i would probably
trend for like five days
and she was serious and he was like [ __ ]
the content the content now like yeah
nobody's sitting now watching david
blaine's
hour yeah like it's just the kids now
like mtv struggling with this because
they were telling me how like the
attention span of the younger audience
is so
small now it has to come like quick boom
boom boom boom
did you see so they're trying to figure
out the algorithm like how can we keep
this young audience because we're losing
yeah i've seen you you've been posting
you're like old sketches and oh yeah
like your sketch shows
holiday all of it yeah i've taken
everything i've ever done
that's what i've done clipped it all up
from like my first commercial
to old college gigs to everything and i
just put words to it try to put it out
for two minutes
and yeah you grew up where i grew up in
philly right outside of philly outside
would you start a stand-up in phoenix
right
no i started stand up in l.a i thought
you started in phoenix
no i i was my first that was my first
club that i ever played where i got to
basically
middle yeah champion probably
dallas improv were like gary valentine
used to let me middle for him rick
overton yeah
yeah all those guys kind of because i
only had wow
like i had done movies and stuff i did
stand up for like five years yeah
couldn't get anywhere i couldn't get in
the improv guest spots maybe at the
store please allows
then i the acting started taking off and
these guys are like you should come
middle because we like you but i would
have eight minutes
yeah you know like and then like the
other eight minutes was me like
working on you know hey where are you
from dude did you know
jimmy i would say like for us when we
were coming up nobody was making money
doing stand-up like
yeah you know what i mean like you with
podcasting now on social media
and you can curate an audience but back
in the day
you just didn't nobody was i don't care
who you were you weren't making the kind
of money people are making well wasn't
standard kind of being used like
you look at some of the staminas back
then they're getting big enough where
they could parlay into a tv
yes you wanted to stop doing stuff
here's how it was you tell me if i'm
wrong it was you get enough
to be a tv guest spot so like eight
minutes on a conan or tonight's show
or comedy central then from there
you get tv guest spots then you get your
own show
and then you start a movie and then you
go by correct
and that and now and then kevin hart
changed the game where he's starting the
biggest movie in the world
he's got the biggest tour in the world
and he's doing a guest spot at the haha
yeah you're like dude
never stop working but it's now because
they want to be with you now where there
was a time where dvds
made made you big again but then the
clubs
there was many levels to it but being on
tv at first they would get stand up all
the time
and then the clubs got empty and then
dvds they followed you you got big again
then that went down then podcasting
made it huge again yeah yeah that's my
opinion what did you do wait when did
you do that movie heckler
heckler was 07. oh seven yeah how do you
feel let me ask you this how do you feel
about when people bring up old movies
are you cool with it or is it like i
love it you like it
but there's like a documentary yeah
about uh
all the hecklers yeah it's a pretty it's
a pretty good documentary well this is
about him getting heckled
well just like it was basically
like i started out i wanted to do my
first hour right so i'd done a bunch of
movies and stuff and i had enough
do my first hour the director's like
let's start filming you
he did and every night there would be
some interaction with a heckle i put
like 15 of them together
and i'm like dude this is funnier than
my act right oh there yeah
and he was like yeah so we had like 45
minutes then we started realizing like
what is a heckler what is in the mind of
the heckler so i started interviewing
all these comics and different people
and then i realized at that time the
internet was blowing up so you had like
blog.com i don't know if you remember
this
and so there was never a review there
was never like you bought a toaster
there was now a review of the toaster
like this was all new so i started
seeing that the culture started becoming
heckling like
and people would say like jamie kennedy
not only should not act anymore
he shouldn't have been [ __ ] born well
if you buy a toaster no one's like [ __ ]
this
this toaster should never be able to
toast together and so
the whole culture became very critical
which is now
in our business we have a whole subset
of people that get famous by taking down
other people
it's fascinating because we're all in
the same games yeah it's gotten
so it was early but now it's this was
before twitter
so i believe we live in a super critical
culture of like
i was just talking about today it's like
not only can you not have your own
opinion if somebody doesn't agree with
you
[ __ ] you for having that opinion i'm
gonna report you because i don't agree
with your opinion yeah
it's bizarro yeah yeah somebody didn't
that spanish politician get
uh suspended from twitter for saying a
man cannot get pregnant
no he really yeah because a man cannot
get pregnant suspended
like we've gotten to a point there are
no we don't know what the rules keep
getting
reinvented right yeah the goal post keys
getting changed and it's really hard to
kind of that's where you start to lose
people where like
what rules are you guys making up and
who's making the rules yeah like who's
saying
that this is the rule it's i mean i
don't know if you can talk about it like
with the virus we could go get a table
you had to wait outside to get your
table and you have to wear a mask
and then when you can go inside to sit
at your table you can take
your mask off because the virus will
wait
i mean that's not a little strange yeah
right it's because what's the message
it's all confusing
it's been an interesting it'll be
interesting ten years to see what
historians say about it all
right maybe making fun of us my god how
ridiculous [ __ ] yeah we locked them down
for it here well that's the thing about
all of history like when you like all of
us should all hang out yeah like every
time i read history i'm like oh
everybody was wrong
[ __ ] everybody for real like like
you're trying to figure it out
yeah all they were giving the cdc ladies
[ __ ] an obviously tough job but they're
like
so two weeks ago you told everybody wear
masks then now you're saying they can
take them off
and and they go do you feel like it was
just pressure from politicians to take
them off she goes
you can see she goes listen man no i get
the info when you guys get there right
yes
i don't have it i do so you guys get it
she's like there's no legit i don't know
that's why i know you kind of
you didn't tell he was like an older
lady and she goes
listen man you get it this is why like
she's sick of that i don't know
i wouldn't be tired of it just listen to
what i said
that's what you know i had this podcast
with sam tripler who i love one of my
favorite people of all time
sam is a it's called conspiracy sam is a
die hard so
conspiracy so uh conspiracy oh yeah you
know and
we and a lot of there are a lot of
conspiracy theorists out there right
yeah so what i'll say with sam is that
the whole point of the show is that he
hits me with a conspiracy and i
i debunk it the problem is that the way
i debunk it i don't really have all the
information but i go
he'll be like they they planned this
they infected bats the cdc's
and i'm always like all i do is i go i
don't think anybody's that organized
i just don't i don't think that the
woman from the cdc is actually getting
orders from
the [ __ ] the white brotherhood or
whoever it is that's running everything
it's it's so interesting to me so like
for me i think that's exactly what it is
everybody's like whatever
yeah everybody's doing their best like i
don't know
how but i went to the mall with my
family and it's weird because we don't
know the rules right and there's
the cdc's if you're vaccinated you don't
need masks and we're all vaccinated
so we don't know so some people have a
mask on some don't it's an outdoor mall
and so i go into this coffee shop and
there's this group of young girls here
and they all have their mask on they're
sipping their coffee through the mask
and even i'm like jesus christ ladies
and then you know people are coming
without mask and she looks around us
apparently everybody's vaccinated
oh my god don't let it ruin your day
but now it's like now it's always great
which is which which is like you know i
have people who don't trust the vaccine
now
they'll hold these [ __ ] how about do
you hear about they're doing the recount
they're doing a recount in arizona yeah
for the election right so
we're doing the recount right right now
maricopa county is that you yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
they're going all right that's me my
frank's area
so the whole thing is we're gonna do the
recount and we're going to show you this
is a legit election right so now they're
[ __ ] they're
literally they have independent views
and they're they're doing the recap
somebody floats a rumor somebody floats
a rumor and what is it
they go hey you guys had re you guys are
counting the ballots
well guess what the ballots the paper
made from bamboo
it's a real thing what is that it's a
real thing everybody
what does that mean meaning china's
involved
that's literally and now they're like we
gotta stop and they have to investigate
that damn
we've gotten to a point where it's
[ __ ] nice you just can't believe
anything it's a thing yeah it's a thing
you ever think about leaving l.a jamie
no this is my home i love it i'm the
same way you know like
honestly the traffic was great up until
about four months ago wasn't those days
you could get here in 18 minutes and now
it's like i'm like oh we're back huh
yeah it took me like 42 minutes to get
here
and i'm like this is this is where i'm
at man i mean we're
people are saying all this stuff about
l.a it's it's gonna thrive
oh yeah yeah always get it
we said that you and i said yeah
everybody's leaving and stuff but it's
like
they did lose a congressional seat
meaning like there's less people in
california but isn't that a good thing
in a way
yeah 39.8 still yeah
that's the number the other thing that
there's a whole stakeholder about people
leaving la and
compared to even two years before the
pandemic this is a natural thing that
happens all the time it's
really not that crazy how many people
are leaving people have been just here
famous people leaving yes but the
overall masses of people even it's
nothing
but people because that traffic is
hectic
i'd like to take drives though like i
did this gig out in chandler
and oh yeah like a five and a half hour
drive i'm gonna do a gig up north
be five and a half i'm enjoying getting
in the car yeah i gotta get on a plane
you haven't been on the plane yet nah oh
here's the thing they've
been unpacked for a while like the media
is like nobody's flying everybody's in
mass dude i've been flying this entire
pineapple
yeah i've never not had it correct
there's only one airline where it was
like
no middle seats i can't remember
southwest delta delta
delta southwest was like that too oh got
it but now
but now like if now everyone was just
like in the middle yeah yeah right yeah
now you're like literally touching
people well you were saying last night
it's like did you guys know that the
ufos were trending last night
and it was a story because 60 minutes
talked about it but it was a story that
rogan broke two years ago
yeah with jeffrey i think favor and bob
laser yeah
no it was in favor of the guy who did
it's the tic tac story oh yeah yeah and
now moving
yeah yeah now everyone's like oh 60
minutes blessed it
but i'm like our community broke that
like two years ago
i also think why maybe that's not why it
gets picked up or trending because
the most the majority of americans are
especially if they're in like
our community or rogan's like it's it's
a vast amount of people yeah dude those
are old videos
yeah so when they show them it's like
yeah we still we've seen that three
years ago i think
anything new i think what's new is the
department of defense
acknowledgedly acknowledged it and came
out and said we don't know what these
are yeah
which means everything's off the table
now right that's what i'm saying it's
all off
that would be okay we all have plans
that would be very [ __ ] like that's
what you don't realize about life it's
like all of a sudden
what ufos are where are they like yeah
that really happened we'd have to be
when it did happen but nothing
yeah eight times no no no no no it's
been happening but what are you doing
but there is still
so if you had if we knew that
actual ufos that that we were being
contacted by extraterrestrials okay okay
again i think we'd still do the pocket i
think we'd still
and i got one because like mars attack
that they're all hostile and [ __ ] i
think there's like
oh you guys are boneheads i'm out of
here yeah we're good nobody would be
like ah
screaming in the streets i think we'd
just be like what's gonna happen
next like the really morbid thing is if
a billion people
god forbid like say corona killed or you
know some virus killed a billion people
it'd be it'd [ __ ] everything up but if
it happened
way over there like you know maybe
like where over there do you think we'd
miss work
do you think that we'd be like you'd
move different because they'd be worried
about it a billion people people goes
a billion you're talking about world war
z sorry i'm talking about you
our lives are completely changing yeah
well it's people leave their home
if it happened over there people won't
leave their home you don't think so
you think i think people died we've been
locked up for
a while yeah now think of a billion
people that exactly we would be
freaked out to be underground it would
definitely be underground but my
question is if if
if we knew it wasn't happening here we
couldn't prove it though yeah they're
worried about it coming over here so we
would be
so lost i agree people people just go on
with their [ __ ]
solid thought yeah but i think i think i
think people will be terrified
who will respond to this pandemic you
kidding me
the thing is this ufos are getting more
and more real i mean
there's a story every kind of other day
in mainstream now no i see it so i think
what are we supposed to do with it well
if something happens i'm like oh damn
that's crazy and then i just
keep on keeping on until it jumps out
you got to see something crazy with it i
got to go to the pier also isn't it
possible
isn't it possible that it's just some
kind of
military technology
yeah and you think that chinese and
russians are so much more advanced than
us we can't figure it out
i think it might be it might be actually
an inside job
no it might be pilots or people in the
department of defense who pick up on
this who video it
but it doesn't mean that because you fly
jets for
the military that you're privy to all
the secrets
yeah that could be a secret military
program somewhere that
just very few people know about oh
you're saying that probably everybody in
the military would not
ever honestly and they're not telling
like oh yeah crazy that's probably an
alien right now
have you heard about this new thing
where they can't this is what's really
eerie
there's there a lot of american spies
and diplomats and it started happening
in cuba and now it happened
at the white house do you read about
this the hot chick no
[Laughter]
wow
to talk [ __ ] about him see who was loyal
came out well honeydeck sounds like
something i ordered dave's hot chicken
right it's a job nice huh it was like a
1 a.m
what is a honey dick
she's a government spy but she's really
pretty so she would get asked out by
these politicians so she would go on
dates with them
then she'd have a recording trying to
get them to talk [ __ ] about trump
and others so she would honey dick
politicians like the cia you should do
that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah but they have
now now that's not what i was talking
about but i like it
but what they have now is they can't
figure out this weird thing where
diplomats and spies especially will be
walking
and all of a sudden they get hit with
something where it's either a
sound that makes them start throwing up
um
gives them a brain injury yeah gives
them a brain injury
so these guys and so when the guy pulled
back he was okay and he went back into
the
the area he got he got a brain injury he
got
really sick had to go to the hospital
immediately they don't know what it is
and it's affecting specific people in
the government
including now for the first time at the
white house
in the doors of or in behind behind the
gates of the white house
really yeah so they think it's either
some kind of a weapon
that a foreign agent or some foreign
entity is using
either its sound frequency that's
discombobulating the brain
or something but it's definitely a
weapon they think that
they don't know about but it's becoming
more and more i heard about this about
two years ago in cuba
that's right it was happening it's
called havana syndrome yes yeah but that
didn't know it was infiltrating our yes
now it's here and it's getting more
prevalent so it's havana syndrome
all these like spies and these guys got
were literally going like this but and
they were like my head
fell to the ground let's go deeper down
the rabbit hole oh damn you guys hear
that do you guys hear the loud booms at
night
why the earthquakes no booms just like
somebody
does anyone hear any booms ever i don't
but i like where you're going
hey well before it was seeing me with
his hair and spirit right now
no but do you never hear any booms like
loud mini explosions
okay go when you go home tonight just
see if you listen what area do you live
in i live in ah by the greek
greek theater los filas yeah maybe i'm
here in downtown
do you think those are gun shots over
there no there's definitely gunshots
but there's also no idea you can look
them up you can look them up i swear
there's booms there's been some weird
what do you think it is
i don't know there was a phenomenon it
was like there was some weird [ __ ] i
liked the way you did it though i like
the way you just said check it out like
whenever you do that somebody you go you
ever sleep in that room
california town puzzle lounge booms
downtown la
all right okay i'm not making it up well
that's like yeah that's right eddie yeah
i've never heard any booms lately
that was a us army training thing that
said 2016 though
right there though march 13th that's
where i'm at i'm in that dimension
[Laughter]
look silver lake that's right i wonder
if it's i wonder if it could be a plane
break like sound barrier
it's just like boom boom now last what
do you think it is
well last year i don't know people
[ __ ] around down the rabbit hole but
did you ever hear the fireworks [ __ ]
yeah
they were putting fireworks in
neighborhoods to let people like make
explosions did you hear that
no dude there was there was a guy uh my
old neighborhood that i lived in
he literally would just stand in the
middle of the street yeah just
light off uh firecrackers why just
because he wanted to
it was like it was like m80s exactly
m80s
specifically and he was just walking in
a little street but
at night when everybody's like lane oh
uh my neighbor had his son uh has a son
with autism and it was freaking he was
freaking him out
and she was like hey you go talk to him
uh she ran right over to him and he was
cool
he was like oh okay i'll leave i'm sorry
about that that's cool yeah she was like
why would he do it like maybe he's like
he's watching this was like this is like
when
when the pandemic like first happened
and then uh he was just freaking out
yeah people just freaking out
i don't know if this dude was just
trying to some people but he was doing
it so comfortably
they get off on that like if you did i
ever tell you about my buddy who's a
defense lawyer
and he has a client this this this very
wealthy family their son
has a problem and the son likes starting
fires
who likes to start a fire and then he
dresses up as a fireman
and he waves traffic around the fire
no yes so there's gonna just go be a
fireman yeah
doing it since he was 14 he's now 20.
so he's still doing it was he recently
in time the judge was like you
get that you know my friends my friends
always got it they pay him so much money
he's a really good defense lawyer but
the kid is obviously a sociopath how is
nolan
like man maybe just whoa he'll be a
firefighter he's like oh
that's a great idea well not you can't
have a firefighter when you're
darning it when you're did he start one
of the palisades well he's like
keeps him out of jail he doesn't start
um he doesn't start massive he starts
fire specifically like a mailbox a
little jewish
oh he's like this and he's got the tough
stuff on and they're like
go go look for colin i'm sure and
they'll does he put him out colin
you want to come with me yo he's like
this
guy's a fire come around this way please
it's a fire and that's
and no one's waiting to talk about white
privilege that's fire privilege
they're like oh colin started a little
fire like what
is that calling single yeah yeah i would
imagine he's
thinking he's got some issues well babe
i'd go start this [ __ ] my son's a good
kid he's an arsonist
he's a narcissist but he's a good kid
but no one thinks it's weird that he's
literally the only person standing there
so one
one of the one trait of a sociopath
sometimes is people
that like to cause havoc like create
major problems
and then watch it happen so they like to
they like to like uh
set fire to a mailbox and watch all the
mail burn and they watch
and they're like i did that and they're
like hey can i help
suck well zero serial killers did that
though
do you guys need help seriously well
it's terrible
yeah i'd be the worst because you could
tell with me right away you guys need
help
[Laughter]
that's just your one line you're not a
good actor like we know what you are
yeah that's that's a condition that is
i'm fascinated with weird conditions
people like to take break in the houses
and take shits on the floor and stuff
and leave
left my mark yeah they don't they don't
want to take anything they just do yes
it is
yes wow people also do that and light it
on fire
a billion wicked thoughts oh really yeah
it's it's okay i feel like it's happened
once or twice but i don't think it's
like a
like a real problem so so like another
person [ __ ] on the ground
i'll do one better they'll do it when
people are in the house and what they
get off on
they'll either jerk off or they'll take
a poo in the house what they get off on
this i might get caught
and i'm doing something naughty and then
they run out yeah so
no i'm sure it happened how do you know
this i read about in the book
a billion wicket things oh that's a
billion wicket thunderstorms it's so
they they took
so these neuroscientists took um all the
data from
from i guess uh pornhub their the mother
thing to see what people actually
look at when nobody else is looking to
see where fetishes are and what they're
about
it's really fascinating and what was it
oh dude you did so so where is granny
porn
the most uh popular well in kenya and
parts of england
why because you're older older people
take care of kids
yeah you know um what is the most what
is the second most popular word
googled in porn sites well it's mommy or
a derivative of that
there's all kinds of weird [ __ ] oh
there's oh you find out what are women
like what what
what do women yeah do we in in romance
novels
do they do they ever mention like
girth or size no they mention passion
you know there's all kinds of weird [ __ ]
it's really interesting so you get a
sense of
how how our brains work man yeah
they're passionate and they're
passionate about that you know the
novels they don't in the on the youtube
they're they're they're [ __ ]
50 shades of grey well get so sized size
is important in the gay community so the
men who are googling uh sir it's
important every community
yeah i don't want book your reading but
yeah well you don't know yeah
do you think women are all about girth
no i'm saying it that's not what they
that's not
you're saying they're not science is not
an issue what they what what it is is
passion they'll talk about
the blood problem i'm saying this book
was written by a small white man
by a shortcut
like in all my years of research women
don't care about you
about your big dad they like you like
short guys
it turns out you don't have to have
money either this is just in in my room
just like
passion i found it here's the answer
there it is
big dicks are out boys gilfs are in in
england
yeah so england's granny wait because
they cause
because uh like oh no so [ __ ] weird
kenya
and um and the you said it came
what do you got chin you have some
current events all righty
this episode of firing the kid with
jamie kennedy is brought to you by
bluetooth bluetooth is making waves
bring more confidence to the bedroom
bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form
at a fraction of the cost bluetooth
tablets combat all forms of ed
can help men gain extra comments in the
bed when it's time to perform
here's the best part bluetooth is online
man it's an online prescription service
no visits to the doctors no awkward
conversations no waiting like the
pharmacy
ships right to your door little discreet
package nobody has to know
the process super easy sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within a few days
it's all online blue chew is made in the
u.s of
a so if you could benefit from extra
confidence in the bedroom when it's time
to go visit bluetooth.com for more
details important safety information
but also a little deal for you try blue
chew free when you use the promo code
fighter at checkout just pay five dollar
shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code fighter
to receive your first month free
and i thank them for being part of the
podcast
first one you guys already talked about
it so you already talked about it
but there was a fire that started on
friday in the pacific palisades
did it hit the west side at all or just
my like my entire house covered in ash
i couldn't go outside not really it
stayed
within the um topanga canyon area
yeah and so right now i think they have
it kind of under control
whereas on i think sunday morning it was
zero percent
had the worst headache my entire car is
covered in [ __ ] ass
i didn't even know there was a fire
because i'm over in burbank it wasn't
until i heard on the radio oh man but i
guess the rain really helped
the rain on sunday morning yeah they
must have got under control because i
was this morning there was no like
smoke it didn't look there's any smoke
on here on the way here it was really
clear
well you you live in wow no but i was on
the way here i was looking at the
mountains oh
and it was clear yeah i didn't see it
now you mentioned i didn't see it either
but i usually take to paying and get
here and like
the wind's blowing it that way though
i'm telling you it was so bad around me
really oh and they think it was
it was started by a person it was like a
you say a homeless man
yeah they said it was homeless man they
arrested two people i believe the first
two people that they investigated they
let go
and they then found that it was a
homeless man that they arrested
well they're all shacking up in the
hills of malibu
so people don't hike there anymore
because they're really afraid
yeah because that's where they're going
they're they're setting up
tents wait so they're leaving the west
side hiking that's correct
and they're up in uh malibu state park
and all those areas
so residents spend all that money don't
hike there especially women well it's
the most expensive property yeah
and they're up there in colonies oh wow
really where
public 405 just up in noah uh in malibu
in
the hills santa monica canyons and stuff
and it's like all right it sounds like
that big from the other guys dirty mike
and the boys
do you remember that from the other guys
the homeless guy
having an orgy in the prius oh no oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah dirty man
also wasn't there like a thirty thousand
dollar reward for this guy
thirty thousand yeah [ __ ] oh that's that
was so funny
that movie's under that movie's
underrated
that's actually adam mckay right there
yeah he's brilliant yeah he's the writer
he's amazing yeah so
with that guy being homeless causing the
fire i mean what are you gonna do what
do you do
i mean yeah arrested but then and then
what and then he's released after
the time yeah millions and millions of
dollars in damage and resources
yeah sixteen hundred acres where homes
burnt at all or just
they had to evacuate evacuated but i
don't think any homes were uh
burning i saw it i did a show a jam in
the van and i saw all the stuff oh you
could see it
yeah you could see it the moon was like
i mean the sun was like it was pinkish
crazy oh damn
wow okay so unemployment is becoming
such a large issue in this country that
a
mcdonald's franchise in florida is
offering people 50
just to come in to have an interview and
people still don't want to come in
because they're making more money
from government yeah how long is this
stimming gonna last though
do we know how long they're gonna keep
doing it yeah there's another stimulus
coming out for
six hundred dollars uh i think within
the next couple weeks
but how long they can only keep that up
for so long
yeah i can't keep doing it well
a lot of people in government think that
you can
you just keep taxing and and just
spending
people are not they're paying them fifty
dollars to go interview just for them
not even necessarily getting hired just
come in and you just come in for an
interview yeah i know so many
restaurants that that can't
hire good they can't find people who are
willing to work because they're they're
at home making more money
yeah it's like it's like a welfare
massive welfare state
yeah so a lot of restaurants now are
going out of their way to
actually pay people a little above
minimum wage now to almost incentivize
people like hey
we're better than unemployment but
people still are like no
what yeah yeah damn so there's a lot of
people with money spending money but
there isn't a lot of people willing to
work right now you see that in your yeah
because they're just making money just
sitting at home
yeah you see that in your getting that
doggy coin yeah
[Laughter]
snl sketch right yeah yeah that's right
and his tweets too
yeah and his tweets was he talking [ __ ]
on it or something
he's yeah he's he talks smack and then
it goes down there yeah
he probably buys it he probably talks
about it
tesla takes dogecoin no they don't take
it anymore
they don't take it no they don't take
bitcoin oh bitcoin bitcoin yeah but
tesla takes
dogecoin uh yes tesla takes dogecoin
because elon
thinks that dogecoin is the future and
then recently he pulled out says that
tesla will no longer
allow bitcoin which is the reason why
bitcoin dipped so hard in the last
wow god he has so much influence on him
yeah he really does
crazy yeah i'm gonna get a test what
else you guys think
okay so somebody is handling the
wingstop twitter account and they are
out here tweeting so goddamn recklessly
they started hitting on a girl who was
tweeting at them
wingstop ranch gotta have nut in it no
way
it's a special white sauce but it does
not contain nuts
and wings up you gotta chill for real
you brought it up
are we flirting right now are we there's
more
wow uh uh
you close texas hq is in dallas so yeah
i'm three hours away be there soon
breaded or naked bread is great because
of the boneless wings but
boning sounds like a better option
god i need you in me all you have to do
is open your mouth
you're a little freak anyways let's move
this to the dms what
yo and then
jesus i don't know when this person got
fired or
promoted one or the other everyone's hot
too
if she's real yeah that's a good point
i don't know if any hot girls really
jamie you know jd yeah
he's great he's hilarious john
witherspoon's son oh yeah
yeah yeah john witherspoon he's still a
lot of things
no he passed away he was great yeah when
he stops about to get fired or promoted
that's
so funny his wings are open
wow what else you got this is nuts okay
so uh this was a rumor a few months ago
but
people recently confirmed that matthew
mcconaughey is actually taking
plans to run for governor of texas very
seriously oh he's
in the works right now to run for
governor wow
i'm going for it it might be caitlyn
jenner and matthew mcconaughey
wow i can see him pulling it off would
you vote yeah
i i mean i liked him in dallas buyer's
club i don't
know i don't i don't know his political
lincoln lawyer he's pretty
uh he's no he's a republican yeah no he
seems in the middle though doesn't he
yeah he sees common sense
exactly yeah i i mean from where you
hear from him yeah
i mean maybe but he's also such a big
name in texas like people love him
yeah love him he could do it he could
probably i've always i have friends
i like him they say he's the nicest guy
on the planet like i've heard
i have a lot of friends who work with
him and yeah all right they say nothing
to me
have you ever worked with him no i
haven't i've heard really just nothing
but good things
yeah i heard he's the best i mean i you
know i would vote for him
i would vote for him based off lincoln
lawyer he's going to wear straps
i love that movie well you know i'm not
going to work you could do it
for sure yeah so right now we have uh
caitlyn jenner matthew mcconaughey and
the rock
but also caitlyn jenner is not going to
win here like could be yeah i don't know
if things are opening backwards
newsome's approval ratings going through
the roof i thought he was in trouble
no he's back yeah he's back oh yeah i
thought because of the uh
petition the recall yeah
i don't know how that works if so he's
got the num he's got enough to get a
recall but the question is
will people but then it goes to then
they have to yeah i don't know
people still have to but his approval
rating now that like the economy's open
back up and our cases are so low per
capita with the lowest in
the country so people like all right
we're good so they're thinking
yeah it's it's it's a tough time to be
caitlin i read that even through the
pandemic
like 56 56 of california still
liked him so he was still above 50
during the pandemic wow yeah
well it's a blue state yeah very liberal
state so of course that makes it i never
heard anyone talk i thought people hated
them but yeah so did i
but it's a blue state so people are
going to vote you know blue yeah yeah
it's like
approval ratings like what is it 52 or
something but it's
it's that's who voted for him yeah
people aren't going to change their mind
but also biden's approval rating for how
long he's been the office when the
lowest of all
right correct it's like the worst of all
time yes in the shorter time what is it
50 50 percent which is which is
essentially historically low the margin
he won by
historically low though for this shorter
time in office
okay i mean you got weird things going
on though they kind of
also the world's different too now but
the middle east is on fire you got the
pipeline issue you got
unemployment's up there's a lot of you
know i mean you can't blame a president
when they first get in there but in his
first hundred dollars they hand them a
bag of [ __ ] on
fire and like dude figure it out yeah
yeah but having said that people are
gonna still blame you
yep a piece of [ __ ] people are [ __ ]
in his house and watching yep
what's that thing yeah
[Laughter]
that's a real problem
ask me if i did and i'll try to convince
you i didn't ready ask me
who's [ __ ] in this house not me
what else you got jen another one of
american idol boys is in trouble
the dude that he likes here with the
without what happened
it says domestic violence like i guess
he has like a harassment charge
against some girl or some girl has it
against him he was on two seasons ago he
was the uh
uh the garbage guy he could yeah he
could kind of sing but didn't have any
formal training historically
like once you warm up he's like warm up
what are you talking about like
what he said i don't know what warming
up is man
okay was he was he country uh
yeah i mean you know he's a grumpster so
he didn't make it you know he didn't
make it but uh
did did did we report last week the guy
the kid who got in trouble
the the country singer who got kicked
out for when he was 12.
put a uh kkk no we didn't talk about
that
american idol contestant 12 years old
yeah man much bigger story than this guy
who finished
900th place yeah the he was in the top
five and he got uh on twitter they found
an
old video that he posted when he was 12
of him
um you know in a kkk style hood yeah
dude he was a fan favorite how they know
it's him
well that's his face there you know
there's no audio though
so he got kicked off american idol for
this and he's in top five
honestly i didn't think that was a kkk
or a ghost like weird right um
yeah they find everything all last night
american isle you know it's like down to
the top
three now it's like so intense he was a
beast he was really good yeah
and all they do is go caleb's no longer
with us moving on
really dude i've been watching again for
[ __ ] three months that's
it there's like caleb's not here anymore
let's focus on you again they didn't
tell you what was
what was up nothing just like caleb's
not here anymore so let's focus on these
three
because they probably can't give you the
detail they don't want
they don't want you to know they don't
want to yeah yeah they definitely could
he had a hood on
no he didn't he wasn't he wasn't
halloween he was sitting he wasn't doing
the hood yeah
i don't know i mean he should have been
like
dressed like a ghost seen in a resurface
with someone oh
he's
yeah i mean he's young there he didn't
even recognize his face i mean
well he's 16 on the show so he said he
was 12 there he was six
well he's 12. 12 though he lost it like
he's a kid
yeah but he's singing country music it's
not
[Laughter]
slippery slow he was a slippery slope no
i'm just saying that you know
what was the state he's in where are we
at here we aren't missing
what's the yeah
might be a tennessee boy i think or
georgia oh okay i mean sitting next to
somebody
it could be anything i don't know well
let's ask chappelle
do you think do you think it was it
looked like a hood it doesn't look like
a kkk
carolina that's that's a tough one too
though
did he say something about kkk in the in
the there's no audio
there's no oh i just thought it was like
he just looks like a ghost head you know
like
but i mean i don't know i could be
that's what it looked like to me but it
didn't look good but it didn't look good
and the objects are bad south carolina
i don't know if you were seen walking i
don't know if you were yeah
oh god we don't want to go down this
road when
you know yeah but at a 12 year as a 12
year old
i mean my my kid is
13 right 12 years old is really young
yeah
and you don't know what the context is
well you don't know
you're if you're next to somebody you
don't know what the context is there
you just don't yeah yeah i doubt history
but also at 16 like
yeah that's what i'm saying what is he
like now like i mean that was when he
was 12. how was he on the show
16 16. so yeah what is what is he like
now that's i mean
i think it's a very a lot older than 16
very solid show
when he was on the show without the
teeth is it garbage
he's beast right it's all his own songs
so he's okay so you're going to take a
minor and you
you saw one snapshot of him and you have
no idea what the context is
and by the way you're not making the
world less racist by doing this you're
not doing any good in the world you're
people think this virtue signaling as if
you're actually making a difference
no you're not no you're not you're just
not so that that's my problem
my problem is the the the hysteria
people jumping on board and saying
we wanna it's just you're not i don't
believe you i don't believe that you're
more virtuous i just don't
i i i just think it's i don't think
american idol and disney's gonna
fight back though i'm like yep get him
out of there like damn no contacts
though he's 16. no contact
was 12 when he was 12. yeah okay if he
was
nine what is the age and what is yeah
but you can't even ask those questions
and that bothers me everyone's scared to
ask those questions yeah this just
bothers me
they're just not gonna put up with it
well now but for them but also
like let's say you were the ceo of
disney would you
like you have this billion dollar
company yeah it's like caleb who
what yeah yeah can he see him with that
yeah we don't have time for that next
truth you're not unless you're
undeniable they're not going to fight
for you
that's true all right so uh this guy
ethan kline he does podcasts i think he
was films that where we do one of our
shows too
um so he's being sued for 50 million
dollars by triller because
he played like parts of the ben asker
knockout which everyone does right
everyone does especially if you're
you know talking about on our show just
commenting but he's actually
playing just like the highlights yeah so
and he was commenting every second
i think 45 seconds or something like
that how do i know if triller has a suit
here yeah because that's
like copy it's like a there's a rule you
can you can use footage just to talk
just to talk about it right
yeah it's all done who is he i think he
said in a podcast too that he
illegally streamed it though that's i
think oh that's gonna be a problem if he
did that
on the podcast he was joking like oh i
illegally streamed it because
he was talking about his uh i
am not i don't know i don't know a show
i know it's big i know yeah
uh he does a podcast called frenemies
with a girl named trisha paytas and they
were talking about that uh
fight and he openly admitted to saying
that oh i
streamed it because he was trying to
talk about a joke saying oh i streamed
it but i still feel robbed
even though i didn't pay for fine and
that's what they're using
in conjunction with the clips i used
clearly that i can get 50 million of
them clearly doesn't have 50 mil
so i'm assuming they sell out of court
but it's not going to be cheap for your
boy there
so they have a suit if you feel they
didn't stream it and they can prove it
yeah they're getting through it yes
yeah how are they going to prove that
because because well initially he just
showed a
photo clip on 45 something on his pod i
think on his youtube channel and then he
also said that he
on the podcast but has been amended
what's that mean is this you have since
been then
it's no longer included
oh it says yes i'm not a defendant now
making minor changes
oh so they're saying h3 just changed
yeah just ethan is
it is
yeah it's like tick-tock-ish kind of but
you can buy pay-per-view with sporting
events and
and right now it was because i saw
with jake's fight yeah are you guys on
it no
no no but i've been hearing we should
get on it you can't get on it or not no
no no no no
what is it it's supposed to be like
trailer is another tick tock
yeah but i heard it is blowing up yeah
it's been around for as long as tick
tock has been the only thing is that
tick tock was more popular
now that uh trailer has fights it's
getting
uh triller's moving the space like a
promotion
it's a bit of a circus as soon as jake
paul loses they're
they're gonna be in trouble yeah
do we know jake paul is fighting yeah i
was wondering we don't isn't he flight
uh isn't he fighting floyd mayweather
after mayweather
takes on logan nope did chandler
chandler um olivera surprise you
uh i would say surprise i thought it was
a good fight yeah i think they fight ten
times
yeah chandler wins five humans that's
why that's exactly
that's how i feel it's funny exciting
that next fight's gonna be
he's he's chandler's so explosive he's
just so he's like the hulk he's actually
the hulk he's a beast
that's unbelievable man yo the jake paul
stuff real right
oh yeah with the hat oh yeah floyd
incredible
nuts that was incredible greatest piece
of promotion i've ever seen
he paid for it but yeah i mean i've met
floyd
a few times in vegas nicest guy floyd if
you're watching i love you
calmest guy i've ever seen i can't you
know he got mad yeah that was intense
man bodyguards don't mess around either
but no he's got something
but i want to watch that fight now oh
yeah he did the footage
i saw but i didn't i don't know if he
actually got roughed up oh yeah
no jake got it i jake got a black eye
yeah oh he did oh yeah [ __ ]
he got it weak yeah his security was
gone
somebody got footage of it where floyd
was hitting him no
oh really yeah but it makes me i'm i'm
in i'm buying like i want to watch it
you're gonna buy the logan paul
why not yeah it's actually i don't know
anything like boxing like you guys do
but logan is a big dude
he's a big dude he's not he's not a
chump
no but obviously he's going against
floyd the greatest ever to do it so yeah
i'm so curious how it does
with that fight as far as like numbers
yeah i think it's going to be
you tell me i think i think to be honest
dreaming i have no clue
and usually i have a pulse on it i have
no clue on this one really
no clue yeah jake was like 11th all time
in terms of streams they said
pay-per-view that's a trailer they're
full of shoes okay so people say
completely full of [ __ ] um i don't know
i just
because i think with the jake and ben
thing there was like this kind of weird
like
ben could possibly win and then jake we
don't know about let's see what happens
and
you know one was a mma royalty and
jake's
up-and-coming boxer so that made sense
with this one it's like
it's so clear that what you know i don't
know
you know what's exciting is you tell me
like there's another family guy
fighting bryce hall did you hear about
this it's a six million dollar fight
so there's something called i forget
it's a family and that head is fighting
bryce hall have you guys not heard about
this
it's a six million dollar fight what
and this is what's exciting because the
whole space is being
yeah so oh that bryce hall is the
youtuber right yeah now he's a big
tick-tock or youtuber but he's fighting
this guy and i forget his page is
something the family
and it's a six million dollar purse
and this is why i think all this stuff
is being disrupted because people are
like we're just going to put on our own
events
agree yeah they don't need anything
exciting from the ufc or anything they
just
and these these what people don't
realize is youtubers how much money they
make in these tick tock guys
so 5 million to them is whatever you
know
but the real fighters like holy [ __ ]
five million dollars like that's more
than i made my career
and these guys just toss it up for the
promotion it's insane it's content for
them
yeah so they're fighting in like two
months six million bucks
i know that's why people can just start
challenging people on youtube
but again but again it goes back to
their like their
demo like their fan base will watch this
youtuber who has no skill in fighting
fight this other handsome youtuber with
no skill in fighting and they'll make
money off of it
but it's like if they go into the real
lanes no one's gonna [ __ ] yeah but
they don't do that
the real lanes are being disrupted
they're becoming almost less relevant
in in boxing a little bit not ufc
obviously no we still
i don't know though no because ty the
tyson fury anthony joshua fight
watch how well that does yeah but name
another fight brian besides that um you
talking about the biggest heavyweight
fight of all time yeah i think
canelo would have to fight can i spot
everybody now canelo used to
draw no i'm talking right no no not
about old like right now i would say i
would say terence crawford if he fought
um errol spence doesn't doesn't beat uh
no logan paul or jake that's still like
another big fight
it would be a big fight but that's not
like a paperwork well worldwide i wonder
though
like worldwide boxing pants but yeah
maybe not i don't know
i'd have to see the numbers yeah i think
i do think that the floyd mayweather
um i'm i'm curious after the jake paul
thing i'm curious to see if floyd
mayweather is going to try to
hurt logan paul as opposed to box him
and it was an exhibition
that's what i want to know i wouldn't be
surprised if if
you see floyd trying to like actually do
whatever he can to
drop him quick and look at make him look
silly oh but
ryan ryan garcia is a big draw not
really
no no no i thought he was social media
dropping on social media but as far as
pay-per-views he's not
i mean dude to be a pay-per-view draw
takes [ __ ] years you got it
okay i mean what about uh uh the [ __ ] is
his name small uh russian guy with a
lomo no machenko is he is he sells seven
pay-per-views
that's it he's just big amongst them
how small how about ufc who are the big
yeah i mean
ufc's i mean they're they've gone away
from the pay-per-view model but just you
know
uh i mean chandler i don't think that
one's gonna be big but
like poirier and connor crushed it nate
diaz they're fighting again yeah
yep nate diaz is a big one like the ufc
is crushing
it yeah it's not even close compared to
boxing
they have so many stars yeah
look at that wow
look at that what did you get jen just
one more um
our guy isaac showed us this isaac yeah
so this is just a what did you see this
i haven't seen it i don't see it so this
woman's supposed to
record them while this guy proposes hold
on oh
there's music so i'm not gonna play this
jesus christ she missed it all
god knows he's gonna do it right now
oh
all right
oh
to her defense it was a little bit of a
down slope
down slope right now i think she was
probably just giggling so hard that she
fell the first time and
you know when your giggles are you can't
control yourself she missed the whole
look
i want to do one thing before we leave
can you that's so funny can you just
bring up i wanna i wanna see if you can
explain this and if you think this is
real magic
can you bring up david blaine with uh at
harrison ford's house
oh yeah kitchen his kitchen dude he did
a little something like this to you but
just watch this
god that was so funny yeah right you do
the top one
seven years ago oh was that seven years
just watch it doesn't matter it doesn't
make a card in the deck
great um hold the day that's my brother
by the way
you're thinking of a card do me a favor
grab ah
grab a pizza grab a piece of fruit for
me like a one that we can open up
you could have it on whatever like
that's a lot of food is there can we can
we cut this
it's not though one we can open up we
can take a knife put it right there
[Laughter]
yes i can cut right through it let me
not hit your hand
let's do hold yeah see
inside see there's see how there's a
card
in the orange no way yeah there's one
card inside please remove it
take it out go ahead pull it out
you know how crazy the hair standing is
so high out of his mind right now
i like his earring shit's dope i just
wanna subscribe
there's so many like david blaine yeah
he's crazy i mean that's now is it a
little weird he came to harrison sports
house with an orange in his pocket
when he opened it did he put it in there
i don't know
how did he get him to have you ever seen
david do a trick in front of you yeah
it's not
so i i did it once and i saw him and he
did the deck
and he and he threw the [ __ ] deck at
the window you ever see that one
and everything falls in the card is on
the other side of the window that's nuts
yeah so i don't know at all black magic
it's just black magic it's just dark
magic i like how they look at me for
that
if you guys are into dark magic he's
racist
[Laughter]
wow oh god
that beard is you just don't care you
don't know save it it's like what's the
point at the moment yeah
where uh any dates i'm uh where am i
going i'm going to
is it here i think my next gig is gonna
be
in um i'm formulating now i think i'm
going to go to austin
and do a couple shows down there and
then i'm going to be at side splitters
i'm going to be at soul joe's i'm
forming all these places now
be here in tampa this weekend for this
weekend i got a wednesday big and hungry
podcast
zany's and then i got uh tampa friday
saturday
and then what do i have oh and then
weekend after that toledo funny bone you
ever done that yeah
okay good and then at san antonio
i don't know i like how you keep it i'll
be
i'm excited then i got san antonio texas
to lol third and the fifth oh then you
got a short flight up to albany
i got the albany funny bone have
now you know what's fun though yeah
because what you can do is because
they're not going to be a direction
yeah so i need you to fly in a manhattan
and take a train a train
and that's only seven hours that's a
great club though it is
yeah all right you never did it no oh
dude you're here
there there there's no six feet it's not
six inches i don't mind but it's a real
comedy
so how many funny ones then philadelphia
helium june 25th 26th
wide open i think so you know i love
that club but is it wide open
leave it because i'm waiting to book it
to it's wide open well i hope it is yeah
i think it is june 25th 22 i don't think
it is it better be
you better hope it is by june i forgot
i'm going to be a delirious in vegas
memorial day weekend i'm so sorry
downtown grant thursday through sunday
yeah uh
chappelle and i are in houston this
thursday friday saturday with david
lucas
houston improv thursday friday saturday
then oklahoma city oklahoma june 10th
through the 12th
at brickstown comedy club get your
tickets to f-a-t-k-z
for chappelle myself and brian and then
i'll be in appleton wisconsin
at the skyline comedy club june 4th
and 5th i think yes june 4th and 5th
tickets at your palace.com
it kids james great thank you for having
me guys
i'll shave next time oh please i like
the unibombers great see you guys